I think the celebrity chef phenomenon
has been,
has gone on way longer than I expected
it to be honest.
Um,
uh,
I have worked at a couple of big food
magazines,
food and wine and bon appetit in
particular,
and I'm the celebrity chef phenomenon
really started in the early to mid
eighties.
It really kind of exploded at that time.
Really led by people like emeril.
And um,
I think it's been fantastic for food.
I really do it because it exposed people
to different cuisines and cultures and
brought everyone's palate's up
tremendously.
I do think it's time for farmers to be
the new celebrity chefs.
I really do.
I think that,
um,
they're kind of connection,
a vital connection to the food is so
crucial and that they need to be getting
more of our claims and our love and
thanks.
And,
um,
while the chefs are a huge and important
conduit to translating those
ingredients,
it has,
it all starts with the farmer and I
would really like the farmer to be the
next celebrity chef.